United Way of Southern Nevada the
sponsors of this segment are hosting
their fashion show luncheon celebrating
leaders in our community and here to
tell us more as president and CEO of
United Way of Southern Nevada Julian hi
so great to see you it's so good to see
you again too Jillian I'm so excited to
be here to talk about women's United's
fashion show and luncheon to be held
April 22nd at Red Rock spa and resort
yeah you had me at Fashion but
tell us a little bit about the luncheon
what people can expect when they come
there sure so our women's United group
for United Way they are the single most
responsible group for the DNA of the
organization and they really help us
inform the choices that we make about
who and what we Fund in the community
and so every year we've tried to for 16
years now get together and celebrate the
women of women United and this year is
our first year back in person since
covet congratulations thank you so much
we're so excited and you have a really
special spokesperson right that will be
at the event tell us a little bit about
once you're in the doors what goes on
and is this red dress going to be there
because I need to come this red dress
and a custom red dress available from
our wonderful sponsor Ann Fontaine you
see some of her beautiful Creations here
so we're so excited to have her as our
fashion partner but our our keynote
speaker will be Dr Desiree Washington
who will talk to the women in the
audience about how to reimagine
themselves for this for these new times
and how to bring new energy and
enthusiasm to the work that we do at
United Way and in their own Community
well I love that it sounds like it's
going to be a very a very fashionable
event but also very important in our
community and if people who are watching
want to come how do they get tickets
let's give them all the information well
I have to tee this up for you okay
tickets are becoming scarce we are
almost sold out and we're so excited I
mean so excited to be sold out but you
can go to
uwsn.org for tickets and we look forward
to seeing you there and everyone else
from our community I I need to come
because I need to see what else is going
to be on these mannequins and Julie and
Jillian we got our Navy suits together I
feel like it's just meant to be you'll
come and you'll start at my table I hope
oh I love it thank you thank you so much
we'll have all the information on your
screen and thank you to United Way of
Southern Nevada again for sponsoring
this segment you can give them a call at
702-892-23
zero zero or visit
uwsn.org W luncheon for more information
all that is right there for you all
right there